parler avec Aymeric Monville philosophe
rédacteur en chef de la revue étincelle
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous on
vient d'entendre avec
l'autorisation du cannabis
et puis des fois
avec
parce que c'est aujourd'hui
alors on a parlé de l'Allemagne de faire
rapport avec la Russie tout à l'heure en
évoquant le dossier de
de changer le jeu géopolitique
ça fait déjà plusieurs mois que
tu es qui donc la nouvelle la ministère
des Affaires étrangères avait affirmé
sur l'opposition à Nord Stream 2 et le
fait qu'elle souhaitait que le crêpe
Integra longtemps alors il faut savoir
que maman elle est vers les grenades
pour la sortie de la de l'OTAN et contre
les gars hier et aujourd'hui il me dit
pour que l'Ukraine rentrer rentrer dans
le temps et
commencer le temps n'est pas la réponse
au Pacte de Varsovie c'était le
contraire c'était qui a commencé à
partir la dissolution du PACS de
Varsovie on s'attendait quand même parce
que
son contrat maintenant
de l'URSS et avec l'accord de
l'Allemagne c'est catastrophique je
crois que il faut prendre la mesure de
ce problème alors peut-être que vous
parlez de négociation qui vont avoir vu
au retour de prime de oui c'est très
intéressant bien sûr tu vas négociation
et ça augmente malheureusement les
enjeux ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
c'est simple la formule elle est très
clair on prend des sociaux-démocrates
comment la chose pour faire des mesures
les plus gentils sociale parce que ça en
tout cela et on prend les parties dit
Pacifique pour prendre les mesures les
plus de la gérance
au nom de respect de minorité nationale
en 45 c'est la Charte de l'ONU et c'est
contre la gérance dans la vie des états
au nom du principe d'une minorité
de jouer sur les minorités comme on
l'avait fait l'Allemagne nazie pendant
par exemple c'est pour ça qu'on est
interdit ça
ce retour de l'Allemagne ce retour de la
police se sont les Verts ce sont les
verres au Kosovo
tu verras tout à l'heure c'était la pire
politique parce que soi-disant de gauche
y a rien de pire qu'une fausse gauche et
droite
pour les questions de la de la pêche ça
va être très très très dangereux
[Musique]
c'est effectivement très très dangereux
et les rapports de force sont en train
de charger parce qu'encore Madame Merkel
participer aux fonctions mais en tant
que l'ancien
par les Russes elle a priori elle avait
une sur
120 portes quoi sur la Russie fait
partie la population
de la France
regarde ce que ça signifiait
l'affrontement de l'Allemagne et de la
Russie
en
Syrie
[Musique]
ou non
c'est
exactement
alors que le contrat - ce qu'on dit
travaille avec les organisations
humanitaires pour essayer de régler ça
cette question évidemment tragique mais
effectivement c'est ça qui c'est ça qui
est au village c'est ça qui est en cours
c'est très différente de celle de 2015